permet il y a une semaine que le leader
nationaliste noir sud africain nelson
mandela a été libéré de sa prison ces
déclarations ont montré qu'il entendait
bien conduire la communauté noire dans
son entier malgré les luttes de
fractions rivales toujours présent
fermeté aussi donc mais négociations
semblent être les mots d'ordre de celui
qui a passé je vous le rappelle
vingt-sept années en prison et qui
depuis sept jours maintenant réapprend
aussi à vivre en famille dans sa maison
de soweto la ville noire de johannesburg
c'est là que l'on suivi nos reporters
martin laroche joubert à l'insa le
village oublié la willie nelson mandela
à plus de mille kilomètres de soweto où
il y actuellement
ici pas de télévision personne n'a vu
l'enfant du village franchir les portes
de la prison
même sa soeur qui attend ce moment
depuis 27 ans babel on les deux soeurs
encore de nelson mandela
nous déciderons de l'emmener avec nous à
sauver ma belle n'a jamais quitté son
village si ce n'est pour de courtes
visites à son frère emprisonné
ce matin elle découvre soweto nous
espérons nous aussi grâce à elle
rencontrer nelson mandela d'une manière
moins formelle que dans ces entretiens
conditionnement programme et babel est
un peu craintive
elle n'a pas eu le temps de prévenir son
frère de sonorités
que nous découvrons à nelson mandela
très décontracté qui lorsque je lui
demande quel est le secret de sa forme
non répond par un compliment aussi ne
pas rester en forme
non je n'ai pas de secret si ce n'est
que j'étais en prison
vous avez deux sorties mieux ou moins
bien qu'avant à la fois mieux et plus
bas là lorsque être en prison est
quelque chose de traces j'ai perdu 27
ans mais en même temps j'ai pu m'asseoir
réfléchi et sur ce plan là j'ai beaucoup
gagné
c'est donc mieux épi est très mauvaise
et à saint-gaultier vous le plus
actuellement
j'apprécie le fait que je suis tout près
de ma femme ma femme bien aimée plus
avancé t seul chacun de notre côté
pendant 27 ans et puis je suis parmi mon
peuple
la famille les amis ils m'ont très bien
accueilli
à quoi voulez-vous arrêté prochaine
c'est difficile à dire
ce n'est pas moi qui décide
personnellement et le comité exécutif de
la ftf
oui très heureux qu'ils peuvent dire ce
que je veux ou pas a du coup
une réponse très politique qui suit les
dirigeants la nc sont en réunion en ce
moment à lusaka en zambie et des zones
mandela devrait rien dire qui puisse
compromettre son arrivée là bas
la semaine prochaine ce qui n'empêche
pas de rattraper en ce moment tout le
temps passé en prison de visites en
rendez vous il paraît à fatigables
malgré la modestie de sa liaison
on dirait qu'il est actuellement de
chefs d'état d'afrique du sud
la officiel frederik de klerk l'autre
dans l'ombre d'elles seulement des noms